okay time to make this video I've been
privileged to do science Communication
online about the climate crisis as my
full-time job for nearly seven years now
but based on recent events I don't know
how much longer I can do this so far
this year I've made two videos and
they've both done very badly they've
both got somewhere between a half and a
third as many views as I'd expect by
this stage and that forms part of a
broader trend for the past year and a
bit now videos on my channel have been
getting fewer and fewer views on average
in 2022 I made 24 videos and four maybe
five of those actually got what I would
consider a successful number of views
and that's a problem because views
correlates with Revenue not perfectly
but there's a pretty decent correlation
between how many views you get as a
YouTuber and how much revenue you can
bring in I'm simplifying here but the
three main pillars that I support this
business with are Google AdSense so ads
appearing on my videos sponsorships
sponsor slots within videos and patreon
and the first two of those pillars are
highly dependent on views with AdSense I
get paid about2 on average for every
thousand views I get on a video with
sponsorships it's a bit more complicated
and I can't talk about it as much but
sponsors will pay more the more
conversions you can get to them and that
is reasonably correlated not perfectly
correlated with how many views you get
on a video for the past two years now
most months my business has been making
a loss and that's actually been
sustainable up until recently because in
those months where I did make a profit
it was a considerable profit because I
was able to do some presenting for
someone else or I would make videos for
someone else or I'd release a video that
did really well and so the channel was
sustainable views the tail end of 2022
were actually pretty good but the
overall trend was definitely downwards
and then last year everything went wrong
as longtime viewers of the channel will
know early last year my dad was
diagnosed with terminal cancer and he
passed away not long afterwards and in
the aftermath of that happening I took
two months off I simply couldn't make
videos in that time and I needed to be
there to support my family to support my
mom and to be an executive of the will
and in that time all all momentum that
the channel had built up basically
fizzled away you see YouTube
recommendations are partly based on
recommending you content from creators
that you've recently watched and so
because I wasn't making new videos my
old videos weren't being recommended to
those people and so my back catalog
views just evaporated I was then able to
go back to work for a couple of months
and get a little bit of momentum going
and made some videos that did quite well
and then I took more time off because my
daughter was born and that may be a
surprise to you even if if you are a
long-term viewer of the channel because
uh I did make a video about it but it
just didn't seem to really go anywhere
before paternity leave I could afford to
take a month actually a little bit less
than a month off and then I needed to
come back to work because at that point
all the reserves that I had built up
over how many previous years had
completely gone and in the time since
she's been born not very much has
changed the channel hasn't really built
up any momentum Revenue has continued to
fall business reserves are completely
gone and my personal reserves are now
almost completely gone and the problem
is fundamentally views ultimately more
views means more Revenue coming in and
it's the most explicit in Google AdSense
in 2022 Google AdSense brought in around
£600 a month last year it brought in
around 900 a month and last month it
brought in
£400 basically unless I change something
I simply can't afford to keep doing this
as my job I want to be very clear by the
way that I'm not blaming YouTube or the
algorithm here I'm not saying I've been
making good videos so I think I have
been and the algorithm isn't rewarding
me though I will note that this isn't
unique to me I've spoken to several
mediums scale educational creators
people like my size and larger channels
as well and they're all struggling
educational content supported by
appetizing seems to be in a really rough
spot right now so it's not just me
but unlike a lot of those other creators
I I simply can't afford to wait out this
storm after last year I don't have the
resources to do that but I can't blame
the algorithm because if I made videos
that people wanted to
watch they'd watch my videos and
sometimes they do several times last
year I made a video that really
resonated and it got quite a lot of
views and that's great it just didn't
happen often enough for it to be viable
though I will note that several people
have contacted me to say that even
though they have all notifications on
for my channel YouTube still doesn't
tell them when I've made a new video
which
is frustrating to say the least
regardless looking at the data I have to
accept a painful truth while I can make
good
videos I don't think I'm a good YouTuber
at least not anymore as I said I've been
making videos as my full-time job since
2017 and in that time this website this
app has changed a lot the way that
people interact with YouTube now is very
different to how they interacted with
YouTube 7 years ago and certainly very
different to how they did 7 years ago
before that yet I think I've been still
approaching making videos like it's
2017 starting with me knowing something
or learning about something and then
making a video to teach you about that
thing starting with me and ending with
you and that just doesn't seem to be a
viable approach anymore at least not for
me in my opinion new channels that seem
to do well and channels that get views
very consistently seem to be those that
start by asking what does the audience
want to know about and then finding the
overlap between that demand and their
own expertise maybe that seems like a
semantic change like rearranging deck
chairs on the Titanic but I can assure
you as a creator that completely upends
how you create videos how you come up
with the ideas and structure the videos
and title and create thumb nails for
them and I think it's the change I need
to make for this channel I should point
out this isn't the first thing I've
considered I've tried to create new
revenue streams by making exclusive
content for nebula by launching a whole
new podcast by doing presenting work and
Consulting with other creators about my
titles and my thumbnails but so far
Revenue has kept falling I could cut
back on outgoings though they are very
limited the only large outgoing is
paying for my editor who I pay almost as
much as I pay myself though actually I
haven't paid myself in 3 months I could
part ways with my editor and edit videos
again myself but that would mean lower
quality videos less frequently and I'd
be able to offer less as exclusive
content on patreon so Revenue would fall
and I don't think it addresses the root
cause I'm not making videos that people
want to watch and that's down to me and
again I think my Approach here's the rub
I have a couple of months Max to try and
fix this and if I can't fix this if I
can't bring this channel back to life
then maybe I can't do this as my job
anymore so in the next couple of months
you're going to see a pivot in the kind
of videos I make on this channel and I'm
not I'm not proposing to suddenly start
churning out content or start putting
out controversial opinions about
subjects I don't really understand that
would be irresponsible based on what I
previously said I'm going to try and
make videos that answer questions you
have about the climate crisis and
surrounding topics and maybe you don't
even know that you have those questions
and maybe you won't even notice that
this pivot has taken place but for me
this is huge this is a paradigm shift in
how I fundamentally do my job and it's
scary this feels like the final role of
the dice I have been incredibly
privileged to make a living talking
about what I think is the most important
issue in the world the climate crisis
and I genuinely think that talking about
climate is the best use of what limited
talents I have this is the best thing
that I could be doing and it's been
viable it's it's supported me and my
editor and I've enjoyed doing it but
changes in the industry and not keeping
up with YouTube and recent events
have just meant that it's not viable
right now at the end of the day me
making a living isn't just about what I
want to do anymore I have a family to
support and maybe talking about climate
is something that going forwards I need
to do in an organization or I do
alongside something else maybe I make a
video on this channel every couple of
months alongside a regular job the
fundamental thing is I've got to provide
for my family it's as simple as that
I've loved doing this job
it's really bloody hard and you have to
work really long hours and do like 10
jobs all at once and travel a load and
deal with some really awful people on
the internet but I've enjoyed doing it
the upsides outweigh the considerable
downsides this video isn't me asking for
help I'm trying to just be transparent
about the situation I'm in about the the
problem and what I'm trying to do to fix
it if you do want to support me then you
absolutely can I have a patreon I
actually have these are my executive
producer patrons over here I'm
incredibly fortunate to have a community
of people who support me on patreon
without their support I would not have
financially survived last year I I I
can't stress that enough the past
several months of videos have only
happen because of patreon support if
you've heard all of this and you'd like
to help if you'd like to make me a
little less dependent on Advertising
Revenue then thank you there'll be a
link down there in the description to
the patreon but this is the deal right
now things aren't working and we've kind
of reached a crisis point and I think
we've reached that point because of me
and so I need to make some changes and
if I can't make those changes and make
things work in the next couple of months
then I think I need to call it a day on
this YouTube channel in the form that
it's come to be at the very least and
maybe that's okay maybe I'll just run my
race here on YouTube but I think that
the stuff I talk about isimportant
important and I enjoy doing it and so
I'm not giving up without a
fight so thank you for
watching thank you for everything and
I'll see you in the next
one